I spoke with a senior official on the
Trump transition team who told me that
Elon Musk arrived shortly ago in his
meeting with chief Trump's strategist
Steve Bannon as well as Jared Kushner
who of course is having an increasing
role within the Trump transition team
and is expected to have a key role
within the administration also present
at the meeting is Steven Miller Trump's
chief policy advisor now I asked my
source what it is they're going to be
talking about and it is a wide range of
issues related to job creation musk of
course is positioning himself to be a
national leader on new transportation
methods and of course Steve Bannon is
expected to be the architect behind
Trump's proposed infrastructure stimulus
plans so a lot happening here behind me
inside Trump Tower not only with the
upcoming US Intel briefing but also some
key staff meetings between Bannon and
Elon Musk right and that Intel briefing
so far as we know hasn't happened yet
right Kevin has not begun I did speak
with a senior aide to vice
president-elect Mike Pence who tells me
that the Vice President is inside and
they are expected to begin that briefing
within the the afternoon what if members
of the transition team told you about
that connection between Washington and
Silicon Valley obviously Peter Thiel
very publicly is trying to make that
connection stronger than it has been
during the administration by all reports
he sort of an odd man out when it comes
to Silicon Valley's involvement in
Republican politics in Washington DC
how much stronger is that connection
getting could we expect Elon Musk to
take on any sort of public role in
strengthening those ties I think you are
going to start to hear from people like
Elon Musk as well as Peter Thiel about
these issues of course it's not just
infrastructure spending and and stimulus
spending but also on the issue of
cybersecurity I think that both of these
folks have a key role to play but again
I think that just seeing that musk is
meeting with Bannon and Kushner as well
as Steven Miller is a clear signal that
he is positioning himself to be the
go-to person on these issues related to
infrastructure as well as potentially
even cyber as the ADIZ economic job
issues become more permanent as we inch
closer to January 20th on on
inauguration day